[Music]
there you have it Mary
that's missiles wait that's home you
stick to your rooms and your rooms only
no exploring no talking about I didn't
ask to be here
[Music]
I assure you who are you my name is Mary
Lennox and my uncle owns this house I'm
Colin Craven my cousin's want this house
was filled with happiness now my father
wants me locked in this room it's
unforgivable I need you to keep secret
you know a magical place where the birds
sing for you
you need to see it we could go outside
who knows you might feel better
hey are you [ __ ] hello
[Music]
you know what your risk it's worth the
risk
this is our garden and it can be
whatever we want
[Music]
there are even more sequences garden a
mother's made the space magical I knew
you were hiding something if you cause
me trouble I'm obliged by law to have
you sent to school
only to break little Whitley stay away
from my son I was trying to make expect
how's this this garden
it's capable of extraordinary things
[Music]
you